-You know our next guest fro
the critically-acclaimed sho
"This Is Us." New episodes
air Tuesdays here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Oh, hey.
-Hey.
Thank you
for the edible arrangement
It is elaborate, Kev.
And kind of romantic?
-Was it?
Oh, see, I told them
to take it easy
on the chocolate-covered
strawberries.
I just wasn't sure what
the appropriate gift would b
for when the birth mother of
your twin sister's baby
is being induced.
-Uh, it's actually a Tesla
-Well, okay.
They were all out of chocolate
covered Teslas, alright, so...
-Please welcome back
to the show Justin Hartley
How are you, Justin?
-Hey, what's going on, man
Good to see you.
-It's good to see you, too
Now, this is very exciting
On the show,
you're about to become a fathe
for the first time, but in rea
life, you have something
which is very exciting
but also a little terrifying
You have a 16-year-old
who is learning to drive.
How has that been?
-Yes, that's right.
"Learning" being
the operative word.
And it is terrifying.
You know, there's nothing
more terrifying, actually,
than taking your daughter
or son, your 16-year-old
who knows nothing about drivin
and putting them
behind the wheel.
It's the worst thing
in the world.
There's got to be
a better way we can do this.
You put them behind the wheel,
you take them around the street,
then you keep expanding.
And we're at the point
where we kind of are,
you know, on the freeway
and stuff.
So the other day,
I take her out,
and I'm doing
a father/daughter thing.
I'm trying to teach her
how to fill up the tank
with gas and all
this kind of stuff.
I'm thinking we'll maybe chang
a tire in a couple of weeks.
We fill up the tank, and I'm
getting, you know, comfortable
and I go into the gas statio
and I have a sweet tooth.
So I just stock up
on gummy bears.
And I'm in the car and she's
driving and she's doing great,
and I'm in the passenger seat.
I'm kind of feeling loose
and I open up the gummy bears,
and as I'm eating them,
I'm shoving them in my mouth
like a child, and I look up,
and we are cruising throug
a four-way -- a red light
with, I mean, just reckless --
she could not have cared less.
She was just --
and I just looked at her,
and we pulled the car over and
then she realized what she did
and I just looked at her
and I said,
"That could have been
my last gummy bear.
You have to be more careful.
[ Laughter ]
And so we were okay.
My voice stayed -- you know,
tried to stay calm
and everything
because the last thing you
want to do is start yelling.
It just makes
everything more tense.
-Well, I just want you to know
I think it takes away
a little of the edge
of authority when you're,
you know, mowing down on a bag
of gummy bears as an adult man
-Yeah, yeah, well,
that's the thing.
I was, like, shoving gummy bears
in my mouth,
and she's not really taking me
seriously, probably.
But we get home that night
and this was, like,
the night before my birthday
I just celebrated a birthday
and it's raining in California
And I kind of look at
my girlfriend,
and it's late at night.
And I was like,
"You know, let's swim.
Why not?
It's raining in California
It's kind of romantic.
It's my birthday tomorrow.
Let's go swimming."
So we go swimming.
We get in the hot tub.
We're having a great time.
It's like 3:00 in the morning,
and we're ready to come inside
and as we're coming in,
I have a sliding glass doo
that my daughter had locke
when I was in the pool.
So now it's raining,
and now I'm getting cold,
and I have to walk all the way
to the front of the house.
And we had just watched th
documentary the "Night Stalker."
[ Laughter ]
But here I am at 3:00
in the morning,
knocking on my daughter's
bedroom window.
You know, and she's probably -
and I'm like,
"This is going to scar her
for life."
I mean, of all the things.
Finally, the dog wakes up.
She answers the front door
She opens the door
and she looks at me
and she goes,
"Why are you here?"
And it dawned on me
what she meant was,
"I can't believe
you're still here."
And I was replaying the events
of the car,
locking me out in the rain
on my birthday.
And I was like,
"My daughter is --"
And she's 16.
"She's trying to kill me."
-Yeah.
-And I thought,
"Now I'm going to sleep
with one eye open.
I'm with this person
who is very, very dangerous.
-No, I think we're about
five years away from watchin
the Netflix documentary
about how it ended for you
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Exactly.
Well, at least I got five years.
-You got five years.
So, you know, obviously,
"This Is Us" is a show,
maybe more than any show
on television,
about sort of
the closeness of family.
You guys have
an incredibly close cast,
as we've discussed before,
and yet you're filming the sho
in a time where
physical closeness, at least
is not a good idea.
How has it been on set?
-It's just that.
I mean, it's tough.
We're lucky --
We're all very lucky,
first and foremost,
to be working.
And I think the stories that
we're telling are important.
And I think it's what the worl
needs right now.
That said, you know,
it is different.
It's difficult
to be around people
that you love
and that you admire.
They're family.
That's my family.
And you can't --
you can't hug them.
You know, you can't touch them
You can't --
We're talking to each other,
like, Sterling and I will
be in a scene together.
And we're sitting in
these makeshift --
they're sort of like --
it looks like a shower.
It's, like, plexiglass
with a shower curtain.
And you're in a box.
He's, you know, he's a foo
away from me,
but he's on the other side
of the plexiglass.
And so we're talking, you know
through plexiglass.
It's strange.
But what's also interesting,
Seth, is how quickly
you get used to the new normal
And if you look at what's goin
on from a distance, you're like,
"Wow, everybody's in a mask.
It's not safe
to be around people.
I've been home since March
Haven't gone anywhere
except to work.
And my daughter tries to
kill me in the car."
-[ Laughs ]
-But you get used to it.
It's so strange how --
And that's the creepy part o
it, I think, is that
you start to get used to it.
I don't know how to talk t
people anymore.
So I'm, like, turning into
a caveman.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, I feel like
you've at least faked it
very well today.
It felt like the normal Justin
-Thank you.
-Hey, man, thank you so much
for making time.
So excited to see new episodes
It's always a pleasure.
-Thanks, man.
Always good to see you.